dans ce point de dépôt au centre-ville
de montréal on peut apporter toutes
sortes de canettes et de bouteilles dont
les bouteilles de vins qui seront
bientôt consignés l'endroit est géré par
la coopérative des valoriste qui
participent à l'un des sept projets
pilotes mis sur pied par québec pour
tester l'élargissement de la consigne
quand il ya un système de consigne qui
fonctionne bien ça fait qu'il ya
recyclage en moins à faire puis on le
voit en colombie britannique on le voit
aux états unis et c'est ça que le québec
est en train de faire en ce moment c'est
draft frappé ce dix ans de retard dans
lequel on était jusqu'ici que ce soit
les bouteilles d'eau de vin ou encore
les contenants de lait et de jus tous
les récipients de plastique de verre et
de métal d'un volume de 100 millilitres
à 2 litres seront consignés à partir du
printemps 2023 des consignes de 10 m
dans la plupart des cas ils de 25 cents
pour les gros contenants en verre
l'objectif elliptique 50 mille tonnes de
matières recyclables se recouvrent
dépotoir chaque année j'espère que ce
matin on en voit signal comme quoi c'est
arrivé si blanc on va de l'avant et que
oui ça va nous aider à changer la donne
c'est ce qui met en marché et qui
distribue les nouveaux contenants
consignés comme la société des alcools
et des supermarchés qui seront
responsables de les récupérer le réseau
devra compter mais 500 points de dépôt
dès sa naissance pour desservir la
population est possible rétorque les
épiciers même si québec a repoussé de
six mois l'entrée en vigueur du nouveau
système nos magasins sont offertes pour
gérer des la consigne 2.0 et son le
répète depuis le début du processus
faute de place dans leur commerce pour
traiter les nouvelles matières
recyclables les détaillants devront
probablement se regrouper pour ouvrir
des points de dépôt ce qui pourrait
nécessiter des travaux de construction
et donc des lettres on parle d'entente
entre les détaillants il faut qu'on
puisse s'entendre avec nos concurrents
dans plusieurs communautés c'est beau
sur papier on parle quand même à terme
de 5 milliards de contenants donc ça va
prendre toute une logistique ils vont
sûrement avoir des entrepôts provisoire
pour faire de la consolidation de
contenant et tout donc on a encore
énormément de travail à faire quand il
est question de recyclage
on dirait qu'il n'ya jamais rien de 6,1
ici olivier d'achat radio canada
montréal